hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my arrow episode 14 video the reason
I have a vixen picture is because she's
next week's episode I'm just really
excited about her so here we go careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen episode
14 yet you guys might not be familiar
with them but the team that was blowing
up buildings in this episode is actually
called the demolition team they're
actually a group of villains from the
comics from the Green Lantern comics the
reason you probably never heard of them
before is because they're super minor
group they were hired to blow up Ferris
air a long time ago they showed up again
during the Omak project's storyline they
got offed but then they came back
briefly during Final Crisis there's just
like a really minor group of characters
there's hardhat jackhammer rosy scoop
shovel and steamroller so I'm totally
cool with whatever arrow wants to do
with them I'm not expecting to see him
again after this episode though but in
the larger context I love the way the
episode played with the idea of secrets
keeping secrets coming clean about
secrets so let's do top 5 WTF then I'll
explain what's going on with vixen and
there is a new round of the reverse
flash ring giveaway it's it's still
going on I started in my flash video all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so number 5 WTF
Merlyn is now officially on Team damian
darhk-- he's working with hive they had
their secret volcano lair damian darhk--
even kills someone through the TV in a
classic James Bond movie he's totally a
James Bond villain how dare you insult
my wife sir
hat tip to John Barrowman for making it
through the entire episode being in a
really big scene with having almost zero
speaking lines that's like going on
vacation for an actor that's like the
easiest day ever
number 4 WTF team arrow repeatedly gets
buildings dropped on them I love the
first one too I wasn't really sure if
Quentin was being shady because Laurel
started questioning him like why are you
getting called out here this is bogus we
find out it's the demolition team that's
luring him there they are working at the
behest of damien darhk's wife although
really she's working for hive so you
could just say that they're working for
hive even though she was the one calling
the shots the way they dropped that
building on Thea - that looks like so
much fun
actors can still get hurt doing stunts
like that even though a lot of that is
made from really lightweight materials
it's just made to look heavy thank you
sound effects practical effects to make
it look like an actual building is
falling on you and there was a whole lot
of D in this episode onto my number
three WTF Oliver
is actually a supporting character in
this week's episode I would argue that
the other characters push him around
more than he pushes them around like
think of it this way traditional arrow
season 1 Oliver has the list he's like
this is what our missions gonna be he
gets a little help from Felicity when he
needs it and there was actually a little
Easter Egg for their very first meeting
ever oh how romantic the first time we
ever met you were asking me to crack a
bust at a laptop but in this week's
episode Oliver was kind of like a
bystander just walking around like okay
I have to go do these things and it was
really Thea that was giving him all the
instructions he needed she was the one
that followed the paper trail learned
about his son on her own Felicity
figures out they're gonna bring down the
building that the Bates gonna be in even
the fight scenes were weighted more
towards the supporting characters
although technically they're not
supporting characters these other team
arrow people those are main cast so even
though the Stephen Amell
Oliver character is like the lead
character it's his show but you're
always gonna see times especially going
forward into future seasons where they
spend more time developing the cast
around Oliver likethey is a really smart
person but unless you show her doing
smart things figuring things out the
audience usually doesn't pick that up
maybe an even better example would be
like having a Cisco episode of the flash
where he learns about using his powers
he builds some stuff to some cool things
and you only interact with Barry
whenever he crosses paths with Cisco but
for you know for the most of the episode
you're following other characters that
are not Barry speed which number two WTF
we have to talk more about Oliver's son
Thea figures out the secret that
Oliver's been keeping and she's totally
on board with it I love the way that
she's always on all of her side it's one
of those impossible choices where it's
like do I choose my fiancee or do I
choose my son at least from his
perspective you know if he comes clean
about the secret then he'll never be
able to see William again and if he
tells us baby momma that he's Green
Arrow
that brings her into this world of
danger and he doesn't want to do that so
that's why in the episode they kept
having Quentin have that conversation
with him about Donna like maybe I should
tell her the truth about what's going on
with hi if I want to keep her safe maybe
I shouldn't tell her he comes clean and
it goes really well Felicity's mom
totally understands but just because it
went really awesome for Quentin doesn't
necessarily mean it's gonna go the same
way for Oliver and they actually kind of
answered that question with the promo
for next week's episode for the Vixen
episode like remember the mid-season
finale where Oliver got the chance to do
something different the timeline
and he's like this time I'm not gonna
tell Felicity because it completely blew
up in his face during the first timeline
when he was like I have a son and
Felicity just flipped out and finally my
number one WTF damian darhk-- captures
all of her son surprise surprise I have
a new friend for you his name is William
when he said William's mother asked him
to take care of William for a while
I wondered what they did to her maybe
they just intimidated her damian darhk--
does seem very evil but he has
principles so i don't think that he
would kill William's mother but I do
think that he has her under threat of
death so the path is clear Oliver is
gonna try and save his son but I wonder
what this is gonna do for his
relationship with Felicity because she's
gonna learn about the son and what this
is gonna do for his relationship with
the baby mama because she might learn
about green arrow stuff even if Oliver
saves the day I don't think it would
make her want to visit him more like oh
hey William your father is a vigilante
fighting crime why don't you go spend
the night with him I'm sure he's already
made you a child-size super suit and a
bow and arrow I know a lot of you are
wondering about Connor Hawke things
because all of her son is not gonna be
Connor Hawke it'll be someone else but I
didn't know that they were gonna bring
his son back and use them as part of
this plot line I think it'll be
interesting but I don't think arrow is
so cruel that it would put a child in
the grave but I do like the idea that it
kills the baby mama and then the child
grows up as part of this broken home in
the same way wally west comes from a
broken home that's usually how superhero
and supervillains stories start they
come from this really terrible home life
one or more of their parents was killed
in a tragic supervillain accident let me
know in the comments though what was
your guy's favorite moment from the
episode and what do you think about mr.
terrific making the technology to help
Felicity walk again here's this chip Wow
you are terrific that may have been the
first time someone called him terrific
in an episode but it was a pretty solid
week I feel like next week's episode
though is gonna be like the big comic
book episode because they're gonna have
Mixon so if the last two weeks of Flash
was escape from zoom Mountain think of
arrows doing its version of that next
week when vixen comes on just to explain
what's going on with vixen in the
live-action universe now they did the
cartoon you may have seen the vixen
digital series maybe you didn't watch it
there were six five-minute episodes on
the CW c-calm it was just meant to be an
origin story for her she'll continue to
guest star on air
in future seasons and she'll probably
guess store on legends of tomorrow in a
future season maybe later this season -
they haven't said anything about the
last couple of episodes the legends of
tomorrow yet
speaking of which legends tomorrow be
sure to subscribe to get that video
sisqó is going to guest star I don't
know what is gonna be doing but I'm sure
it's gonna be awesome remember they have
to rescue all those people from Vandal
Savage who is trying to make his own
firestorm
well guys wait for that video to post
you can click here for last night's
episode of the flash and you can click
here for my guardians of the galaxy to
video they just announced some new cast
members and it's gonna be awesome thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight